now let's get on to the tax bill itself
first from my wardrobe today I have to
thank
oh and Brennan and Justin folk who are
the guys they're the guys doing the
dennis prager and Adam Carolla movie no
safe spaces which is a lot of fun it's
gonna be great when it comes out they
gave me this shirt it says keep calm and
cut taxes keep calm and cut taxes and
both sides of that are important if you
know it's playing on the old British
slogan keep calm and carry on you know
both sides are important the left is
losing its collective mind over tax
reform Larry Summers is claiming I kid
you not that 10,000 people will die
because of reforming taxes Talking Heads
have compared allowing people to keep
more of their own money to rape comedian
Patton Oswald wrote quote is there any
going back after this tax bill scam to
America does it matter now if Trump is
impeached
there's no America now not the one we
knew I'm sorry I'm feeling real despair
this morning I'm sure he is
leftist blogger bill Palmer shrieks
quote millions of Americans died tonight
they debt now you might not have seen
that on the news because it didn't
happen you know but they died quote so
did the careers of every one of those
psychotic drooling animals in the
Republican Party who voted for it this
was mass murder Keep Calm Keep Calm it's
okay baby baby it's okay letting people
keep more if their own money is not mass
murder it's going to be fine Lindsey
Graham laid it out pretty frankly he
said Republicans have to do this if
Republicans cannot come together and
unite on reforming the tax code lowering
rates and reforming the code they might
as well fold up as a party which doesn't
make some sense if you can't convince a
bunch of Republicans to cut taxes but
what if there isn't a Republican Party
anymore so what does the bill actually
do the bill lowers and simplifies income
tax rates doubles the standard deduction
doubles the shot to child tax credit it
preserves the adoption tax credit which
is good it's a good bit of pro-life
wiggling in the the federal government
median income family of four sees a
reduction of $2,200 per year so
Democrats are going to shriek that it's
only the rich who benefit from this
first of all half the country doesn't
pay any taxes so the rich probably
should benefit from this but the median
medium income earners and with a family
of four gets over $2,000 per year in tax
deduction which is a great thing more
importantly it lowers the corporate tax
rate to 20 percent this does matter
people are gonna try to convince you
that it doesn't matter because some
gigantic companies keep a lot of cash
overseas and they pay very little in
taxes but a lot of businesses in this
country do pay taxes especially in
sectors like energy finance retail Home
Depot pays a very high effective tax
rate cable companies waste management
fast food there are a lot of areas of
American industry that do pay taxes this
is going to bolster them it also repeals
the Obamacare mandate this is one of the
best parts it's great maybe we can get
some money out from corporations
overseas maybe we can stimulate job
growth but this this bill repeals the
Obamacare mandate the federal penalty
that requires Americans for the first
time ever to purchase a good from a
private company totally antithetical to
American liberty now that it's past the
difficult hurdle which is the Senate it
seems likely to end up in the final bill
this is great news now for the sort of
bad news the Senate tax plan is
predicted to increase the u.s. deficit
by 1 trillion dollars to 1.4 trillion
dollars over the next decade I say this
sort of bad news because this is from
the CBO and the Joint Committee on
taxation these sorts of predictions are
usually off they're usually hyperbolic
the growth prediction at the root here
is just 0.8% economic growth we have
plenty of reason to suspect that this is
way too low third quarter u.s. economic
growth is already beating expectations
so Trump's first year these numbers came
out just a little while ago already
exceeded expectations for the first time
in a decade actual economic growth has
exceeded maximum potential economic
growth so economists are predicting
stronger wage and price increases
because the economy is operating beyond
its potential this is great news for the
Federal Reserve which is worried for
years about sluggish inflation still
even granting all of that even granting
that probably these numbers are off the
tax cuts might exacerbate the deficit
that's not a good thing so what can we
do about that
president Trump has already signaled
what he intends to do I know you don't
want this welfare reform does anybody
want welfare
and infrastructure but welfare reform I
see it and I've talked to people I know
people they work three jobs and they
live next to somebody who doesn't work
at all and the person who's not working
at all and has no intention of working
at all is making more money and doing
better than the person that's working
his and her ass off and it's not going
to happen not going to happen
so we're going to go into welfare reform
unless Billy doesn't want it Billy on my
okay and saying they speak for you
he said yes not not exactly Reagan asked
addiction but hey that's okay we'll take
what we can get Rubio and Ryan among
others are also saying the same thing
but what does this mean by welfare
reform Trump he isn't just talking about
Obama care for Obama phones or whatever
you know they very often they'll they
would say Trump isn't gonna talk deal
with entitlements but what he's doing
he's so brilliant he's tying entitlement
reform Medicare Medicaid Social Security
which are the main drivers of our
national debt and deficits he's tying
that to welfare reform so the image of
the welfare queen and the the Obama
thumb he's painting a picture of the
cause of our economic woes and the cause
of our long-term problems that we can
digest and get behind we can picture the
problem of welfare and and it's accurate
by the way it's not a lie these problems
are welfare they're albeit that's
welfare that the government has forced
us to pay into for years but it is a
welfare system